et maintenant voici comme villa
[Musique]
m
thierry 2 futon succès de la semaine
dernière à la place de guillon ma tante
a droit à une musique d'entrée
alors je m'emballe pas non plus présent
tout à l'heure il ya eu la répartition
des loges ils m'ont mis dans les
chiottes donc c'est pas gagné j'avais
précisé petit débrief de l'émission de
la semaine dernière thierry gros gros
buzz cristina cordula annoncé que par
amour pour son mari était prête à aller
dans un club et échanger en plus à voler
dans un club est sur liste avec son mari
c'est débile oui c'est comme aller je
vais à la boulangerie qui sont pas c'est
qu'on n'a pas de sens
alors très très beau plateau ce soir
thierry on reçoit laurent ournac laurent
ournac c'est l'homme qui a prouvé à tf1
on pouvait perdre du poids sans
participer à koh lanta
nozay on va en parler deux secondes
c'est quand même extraordinaire ce qui
s'est passé vous avez perdu 50 kg enfin
perdu en fait vous il vous en retirez un
morceau de l'estomac donc la formule
exacte c'est pas j'ai perdu 50 kg mais
j'évite danger 50 kg
[Musique]
d'ailleurs il y en a qui fait la gueule
c'est donc choisi parce que le mec
pendant dix ans il a bouffer de la merde
là du coup il a été obligé de se teint
les cheveux en rose hill fait sosie de
loana alors
[Applaudissements]
non non non pas à 10 pôles publics c'est
zazie pour les impôts et vos parents
c'est isabelle marianne de truchis de
varennes voilà alors vas-y vous êtes
coach dans the voice depuis deux ans et
vous avez déclaré avec jennyfer qui s'en
va je vais devoir porter plus de jupes
ou m un kilt à garou alors je préfère la
première option parce que garou si on
respecte les traditions du kilt si tout
est proportionnelle à sa voix il va
faire peur aux gamins
à merci la halde ahmed le grand public
vous avez découvert et qu'on ne demande
qu'à en rire tiens et le tout petit
public vous a découvert avec l'académie
des 9 sur nrj 12 non non non j'ai
regardé une émission c'était vachement
bien et j'ai fait plutôt sans déconner
et de nice wavre est encore en vie
j'étais pas au courant non mais ça alors
à mettre vous avez fait beaucoup de
scène ouverte à vos débuts alors
j'explique aux téléspectateurs ce que
c'est une scène ouverte c'est le
principe c'était debout tu fais marrer
les gens sans être payés à la fin c'est
un petit peu comme un stage chez
ardisson alors
mesdames et messieurs je suis ici pour
vous poser les questions trop con que
thierry n'a pas voulu vous poser on va
commencer avec laurent ournac qui vous
avez une perte de points impressionnante
a du coup je vais vous poser la question
tout le monde se pose vous avez perdu de
parts ou
non l'avantagent canton
on maigrit c'est que tout ce qu'on perd
en gagne ailleurs non mais en terme de
[Applaudissements]
nombre de morts parce que n'enverra pas
comme ça pas fort on appelle la bûche et
glace
vas-y vas-y avant tout le monde vous
appelez zaz mais depuis que zaz existe
on vous appelle comment zaz la vraie
celle qui se douche
à m sila alors à m vous avez déclaré que
grâce à on ne demande qu'à en rire vous
avez pu tourner dans alice nevers le
juge est une femme ouais si vous aviez
une bonne note vous originaux dans quoi
alors du
[Rires]
gym est en rémission merci
[Applaudissements]
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus